The SCP Foundation works very hard to keep
all knowledge and evidence of their discoveries
from reaching the outside world.
As far as the average person is concerned,
the entities and anomalies documented by the
SCP Foundation do not exist.
Anyone that stumbles upon an anomaly without
authorization will wind up having their memory
wiped with amnestics, or something far, far
worse, but either way, the knowledge never
enters into the general public’s consciousness.
But what if there was an anomaly that even
the members of the Foundation didn’t know
about?
Not because they hadn’t discovered it yet,
but because, somehow, it wouldn’t let itself
be known?
It sounds impossible, but one particular Foundation
researcher faced this paradox while covering
an anomaly that is currently listed in the
archives without a number, referred to only
as: KNIFE.
Junior Researcher Harris was assigned to SCP-4955
one day, and given the responsibility of examining
it and cataloguing any anomalous behavior
displayed by the item.
SCP-4955 was a simple knife of unknown make
and model, about the size and sharpness of
a common kitchen knife.
He took the knife into the lab, and ran the
usual tests.
He scanned the materials, tested for any kind
of radiation, administered thermodynamic tests,
and did everything else that is standard procedure
for a new SCP.
In spite of all of his efforts, he found nothing
unusual about it at all.
It was just a knife, with a metal blade and
a wooden handle.
It didn’t give off radiation, it didn’t
have an unusual level of sharpness, it didn’t
glow in the dark.
By all accounts, it was a completely ordinary,
boring knife.
So why, then, was it even at the Foundation
in the first place?
Why was his time, which could be better spent
on other, more pressing research, being wasted
here?
Junior Researcher Harris decided to present
his highly uneventful report to his supervisor.
It was then, finally, that the strangeness
began.
At the start of the meeting, Harris’s supervisor
had no memory of anything being placed in
P-0055, where the knife was being stored.
Harris confirmed that, yes, there was something
in there.
He continued his report, explaining that the
knife had displayed no anomalous properties
at all, and didn’t seem like the sort of
thing the Foundation should be wasting resources
on.
As soon as he finished delivering his report,
his supervisor just stared at him, blankly.
As if she was expecting something from him.
Unsettled, Harris asked her if she was alright.
She replied sharply, saying she was perfectly
fine but was getting tired of waiting for
him to give his report.
Caught completely off guard, Harris gave her
his report on the knife a second time, only
to be met with the same blank stare.
He attempted to give the report two more times
before giving up and leaving in exasperation.
Somehow, as soon as he told his supervisor
about the knife, she forgot everything he
said on the subject.
Determined to explore this bizarre turn of
events further, Harris set about recruiting
a colleague to help him conduct an experiment
with the knife.
He managed to bribe another Foundation employee
named Researcher Smalls with five dollars
and the appeal of an unsolved mystery, and
he agreed to step in and participate.
As soon as Smalls entered the room where the
research was being conducted, Harris held
up the knife and showed it to him.
He asked Smalls, “Do you see this?” to
which Smalls replied, bafflingly, “See what?”
Harris approached Smalls, holding the knife
right up to his face.
Still, Smalls insisted that he saw nothing
in the room aside from Harris and himself.
The more Harris pressed him, the more Smalls
insisted, with a smile, that he did not see
a knife and had no idea what Harris was talking
about.
In a frustrated outburst, Harris smacked Smalls
across the face with the broadside of the
knife.
He stumbled for a moment, as the blow made
its impact, then steadied himself and looked
at Harris with the same expression as before,
the same expression he had seen on his supervisor
earlier that same day.
Attempting to regain his composure, Harris
asked Smalls, “Did you feel that?”
Smalls grinned at him and replied, “All
I feel is bored.”
Determined to push the limits of his colleague’s
apparent forgetfulness, Harris cornered Smalls
and raised the knife to his face once more.
This time, slowly, maintaining eye contact
with him all the while, Harris used the blade
to make a deliberate, shallow cut across Smalls’
cheek.
The man winced as the knife made its mark,
but as soon as the blade was tucked into Harris’s
pocket and out of sight, he did not reference
it once.
He smirked at Harris, with blood dripping
down his cheek from a wound he would not acknowledge.
This experiment with Smalls brought Harris’s
understanding of the knife into sharp perspective.
The knife itself was not the anomaly, but
rather the knife’s effect on anyone who
observed it.
Everyone, with the inexplicable exception
of Harris, who observed or learned about the
knife, was rendered somehow unable to verbally
acknowledge, or possibly even comprehend,
its existence.
Harris and Smalls met for dinner later that
evening, and Harris was fascinated to see
that his colleague’s cheek was still smeared
with blood.
It had been left to dry there all day, undisturbed
on Smalls’ face.
Several other researchers noticed the wound
and asked Smalls about it, who insisted it
was nothing.
The curious parties accepted his answer, but
only after looking at Harris for a long time.
Though they would not say it out loud, on
some level they knew what had happened with
the knife.
When Smalls wasn’t looking, Harris dosed
his drink with a strong memory recovery agent
developed by the Foundation’s antimemetics
team and attempted to introduce Smalls to
the knife again.
Unfortunately, it had no effect, and Smalls
was still unable to acknowledge the existence
of the knife.
The next day, determined to take his experimentation
to the next level, Harris cut his own cheek
with the knife.
He walked around the facility as usual, letting
his wound bleed freely onto his face and formerly
pristine white lab coat.
Colleagues stopped him to ask what had happened,
and he told them plainly “I cut myself with
SCP-4955.”
Upon hearing those words, each person asking
about Harris’s injury immediately turned
and walked away, covering their mouth.
Believing the knife to be some kind of antimeme,
or an anomaly that resists being recorded
or remembered, Harris administered further
tests.
He ran the knife through a QNTM antimeme machine,
but found nothing.
The knife behaved like previous antimemes,
but was unaffected by machinery designed to
observe them, and was immune to the effects
of memory recovery agents designed to counter
them.
What, then, was it?
Harris was beginning to feel like he was at
the center of a grand practical joke, and
he couldn’t figure out the punch line.
All he knew was that his grip on reality was
beginning to slip, and the knife was to blame.
Harris’s supervisor stopped by his office
to check in with him about SCP-4955, demanding
a report on the anomaly.
At the end of his rope, he responded, “What
4955?”
Just as the supervisor began to reprimand
him for his poor attitude, Harris took the
paperwork for 4955 and shredded it into ribbons
with the knife as his supervisor watched.
As soon as he was finished, he looked up to
see the supervisor staring at him, wide-eyed.
Slowly, she lifted her hand to her mouth…and
began to laugh.
She laughed loudly, uproariously, like it
was the best joke she had ever heard.
Then, she asked him to take a look at SCP-3309
instead.
Harris clenched his jaw, glared at her, and
lifted the knife to his hand.
He sliced open the tip of his finger and flicked
the blood onto her face.
She didn’t even flinch.
Instead, she turned away, laughing, face still
streaked with Harris’s blood, and went about
the rest of her day.
This is the moment where Harris began to crack.
All he wanted was for someone, anyone, to
acknowledge the knife that was driving him
out of his mind.
It was as if the entire facility, including
his own machinery, was gaslighting him.
He decided to take more extreme measures to
get everybody’s attention.
At this point, whatever it took, he would
do it.
Harris marched into the Foundation cafeteria
at lunchtime, carrying his usual bag.
He walked into the center of the room, taking
in the sight of his colleagues.
His supervisor still had his blood on her
face.
Smalls still had a pool of dried blood on
his cheek from his day-old wound.
Harris took a deep breath and unzipped his
bag, pulling out a test rat from one of the
laboratories.
As the crowded cafeteria looked on, Harris
pulled the knife from his pocket and dispatched
the rat with one quick slash.
He held the dead rat up in the air, commanding
the attention of the room, then let it drop
with a sickening thud.
No one said a word, they only watched and
quietly laughed amongst themselves.
Five days later, the rat was still there.
It had been stepped on and flattened by days
of foot traffic, fies were beginning to buzz
around the corpse, and the smell had seeped
into the ceiling and walls.
Still, no one mentioned or referenced it.
No one moved it.
And no one talked about the knife.
The following day, unable to stand the smell
or the sight of it anymore, Harris broke down
and cleaned up the rat.
As he did, he could hear people laughing behind
him.
Every time Harris entered a room, people were
laughing about something, and no one would
tell him what.
Still, when he brought up the knife, even
when he screamed and cried and pleaded, everyone
ignored the subject.
It would not, and could not, be spoken about.
Several days later, Smalls complained that
someone had cut the plants he was growing
in his room.
Even though Harris had not cut his plants,
he decided to take credit.
“I did it.
With my knife,” he said.
As soon as the knife was mentioned, Smalls
sat down and went completely silent, abandoning
the subject entirely.
This gave Harris another crucial piece of
information on the nature of the knife’s
effects.
It did not matter whether the knife was actually
present or involved in something, all that
mattered was the perception that it was.
Even the mention of the knife was enough to
invoke its effect.
The days bled into each other, day after day
of Harris begging his colleagues to see what
he saw, demanding to know what the hell they
were laughing about, and feeling more and
more utterly alone.
Harris’s mind had truly begun to come apart
at the seams.
In the second to last entry in his research
log, he simply wrote: “It’s almost show
time.
Time to give the people what they want.”
The day after he wrote that cryptic entry,
Harris walked up to Smalls in the cafeteria
and tapped him on the shoulder.
When Smalls turned to greet his friend, Harris
stabbed him in the chest.
Smalls fell to the ground, curling up in the
fetal position, and Harris kicked the knife
deeper in as Smalls cowered there.
He did not stop until Smalls was dead.
Harris was removed from the facility, leaving
the knife in Smalls’ body.
Harris was promptly terminated, eliminating
the last person who appeared was able to discuss
the knife.
As for the knife now?
Its current location is unknown, making this
mundane little object one of the greatest
unsolved mysteries of the SCP Foundation.
What was the knife, exactly?
What gave it such a strange hold on people?
In the end, it might not even matter.
After all, what is more frightening?
An object that prevents people from being
able to remember it, or being the only person
in the whole world who does?
Now go check out “SCP-055 - Anti Meme / Unknown”
and “SCP-3999 - I Am At The Center of Everything
That Happens To Me” for more freaky anomalies
that can really get inside your head!